k you for the
invitation so skip the the i don't know
I to so there
was
me Simon conjecture so what it is i'm
sorry
it's begin quite abstract see will go
back to
to
space generalility
space and you have operatorting on L2 of
mu mu being probability and we assume
that it is
selfjoint and said to be marov if
twoerty are
satisfied posi is preserved if I have a
function which is positive remain
positive and the vector which always
taking the value one transform itself so
well
situation in fact think  of S finite set
you have a measure positive measure on
your finite set and M is just a matrix
such that every ent is non negative and
the sum of all on the line
ization
if it is only invariant
but be
reversible so m SPECT decomposition you
can
find you know
this spectrum of operator isary between
min and and you have this should be seen
as vector space generated by V
asso
and
can know
V the
constant function areue for
vectue and Weg in fact if it is the
only Vect associated to
one is here  and so we can use this
projection Val measure saying that
between one and one minus there is
nothing
except the fun constant
this
back
and not just before there is nothing but
there is
fact
and there is in fact no value and weous
spectrum and if it is  happen we that
there isect and the
larger
definition will be all we that M is
bonded if send L2 into some LP into some
smaller space into so for P larger than
two usually it was for four P equ F but
you can ask for any P larger  than two so
the question which was asked by and
Simon is is such an operator which is
self jointgic and H does it have a
spectral Gap
general
is in general but maybe I can
say what you will expect such if
I
have this number so  I should be able to
compute the SP in TER of that this
not which is it is smaller than two then
there is B of lower B of the spectral
gap in term of the difference between
that and two but this is the only case
where du
to  you also the guy ask me the question
so yes it was not for one particular
mark of operat but in fact for of operat
which satisfiesoup condition
all non negative you have operator PT as
before before a mark of operator which
is also self Jo and the satisfi  you can
think
of
the the kernel for instance may back to
that
sogonicity we say that such a semoup of
family of operator is ergic
ev one and SP converence in fact is
uniform over the unit B of L2
of and we said that it is h if  there is
a time such
that
ptend
L2
l and the question was in this situation
is there SPECT gap for Pt so just
consequence of the prev but wanted to
say
but because I say it
later so there was a case which very
easy is when PT is  not only h bed
butrative not only it iSous
as and back later to that so in this
case it was easy and well known because
for people know may jump fast here it
was because if it is h conttive in fact
there is an inequality andity is  well
known to imply a spectral gap
and
you add you
know and
enery
F2
con
if
equal this case of selfjoint Mark operat
you have in fact equival between non
tight Logar inequality and in
tight quality but you have to change
the const and this is non tri  you cannot
do it in Universal
wayeence
er dire but iing that a lot ofequalities
if are not tight in fact you can tight
it quite easily but you lose the
constant and you can there is not a
universal way to transform the
constant
so so now coming back  there is a guy
from back to the
finting
andk ofern but mark of generating it me
so you know it's a mat and the mat
outside the diagonal the are netive and
you put in the Diagon needed such that
if you take them over the L it
is  since ass
is is rsible respect to the
meure it fact diagonalable and
youectum as
before min the spectrum of
L
positive and
inequity
lambda to
quting
the
take RA between so you inter respect to
take the respect case over the point
which are a and you take the  which are
not in a so maybe I
should just to see may
allu
B of qu just
x
not
num
of consider the usually you consider
this minimum over all a whose mass is
less than one half but in fact you can
write it over all set just  taking the
maximum you see because this is
symmetric between a a and the
complementary of
a so you get that and this is called
sometimes the trigger constant and the
result we have seen in the prev talk is
that lambda can be estimated using I2 is
less than this  is trivial because you
just consider the indicator
function and here you have here well I
have to put l because you see everything
is homogeneous in L if I multiply l by
something the the spectrum is multiplied
by the something the same and also here
you see it's  linear in L so since there
is square I have to divide by something
and what is that
weight of getting out of
point
so this
iSous for
theue is it possible to C the space
into component
souce
ntion and you consider the maximum of of
the but you  take the minimum so in fact
when you will optimize there will be
all in a certain they will be all the
same in fact when you make thetimation
because if one is
bigger so in
fact I was wondering if there is a
constant Universal constant depending on
n  that is always true for any finite set
for any measure mu for any kernel which is
reversible and so came from
from
and or from the prev
of
so we
get was that we can
in fact not important I will need is
thatn is positive if I give  you I don't
care
about you compute it but I just wanted
to be positive what the choice so you
have shown that it is can take for
instance not in the
ofk
of you can to the
other because you
s
to so what can and this  will be ingent
to solve the conjecture so why it is now
I
will
consider is stupid because we know that
in the finiteting
L2 important want something
quantitative so the is the following
no I forget that I had a generator but I
come back to the kernel so  now the sum
is one no longer zero uh and the
spectrum so it's is MVE it is between
one and minus one as initially Tha one
th two this again value and the is the
following CN is a constant we have seen
if whichose
to
if
should is  small so if you have a lot of
between one and small
quantity then for ifute
the then can
should
not so in fact it's quite easy if you
forget that assume that as you saying
that you have n value which equ to one
so in fact it me  you have
n which are not communicating between
themselves if you
compute easy
all if indicator of this function here
there is A1 A2 your set you take for F
this indicator function and you take one
of them is of a measure less than one
over n you take  this one and you get
this B this is almost immediate and now
from
this case to the other case you have to
use something quantitative and the
quantitative it was the higher order go
in the same direction so this is a proof
but
I J that very
easy Ian  P
you but so is finite set and you have to
go to the
general setting but in fact for mark of
kernel what you should always finite you
can very well approximated by
finite mark of CH so
i you won be B and the of the H bond  h
bond in fact because we use an argument
by
contradiction and so let's see what
happen if there is no spectral gap if
there is no spectral gap me that between
this
two
lace
proje je fact dim it
meum if
there spectum
go so there will be
anite  this be ok but just what was
saying so now you will make
approximation you some N and
mayx
if ofernel in your general stateace and
you have you will
conr which is
finiteeld
finite since we are working with
function you are using function once you
have fun you  separable and you can make
apprximation
ifield is you can associate Mark kernel
the
level
m g procure mark of Carnel Sigma field
you can
assoate operation monotous
respect qu
sp
usexation
ok
ah
backument
justximation using and if there is you
ch ofose
to so you see what
we
and
we work finitek get
B for that and then go to the limit
and but we could have done the other way
was first to extend the higher trigger
inequality to the general case because
it was some question this morning we
would like at least to recover the
setting  of initialting of which is a
compa manifold so to do that
will all
the so we def that which is
rel
ratio M is Mark of the entity should be
seen as a generatork of
generator so this quantity you
recognize form and you div the by the mu
F2  and
by characterization of
shouldue for
theite in the not because if you have an
essential
spectrum once you reach essential
spectrum you get stuck to SP because you
have anite number of function so this is
not necessary value but is to the
this is exension of the LDA  n we have
before
foruc
and you take the
minimum cting maybe not partion
but
max
and that but since we would like work
with la la is
not mark operator Mark generator so we
should go from
theoup for instance
to
coup if gener since
we of
the
this  elementary computation
so here be easy to to the
limit is underst something which is
small and here everything is
but not for the
connectivity
fact using indicator function of and go
very back to the limit
when so we have to find something else
so the idea is to  introduce a
spectrumectrum another spectrum which is
between the connectivity spectrum and
the usual spectrum so in the
connectivity spectrum we were using this
ratio of this isimetric ratio we will
replace it by
LDA so
l assume you have your mark of Carnel and
you have a set and  I should say that of
M of a for who are working
probability this is giving the weight of
a mark of chain associated to M to get
out of
aalytically like that
outside
and function of the RA of form by mu of
F in the setting for instance  if it
la
since diff
notumingin
sinces the you take that and you
replace
before in the definition when
you connectivity you replace it by this l
this as you see from the definition
is asso
to and qu
yes because it was introduced introdu it
with toudy something in  independently by
in the context of the of
several because you can if you the
everything isinition
and
know
so ah I didn't but there will be
relation
between this is in fact to apprximate
theue
fact by procedure as because the
procedure
is no with it  but now we have an
advantage and you see there is no square
and this is important in fact the idea
this is true it came from a simulating
maybe I will give
an explanation why it is after that but
it's important there is no square and
you
yes
spectr
apprximation
okoupoup
ou function you don't care what's
outside a by indicatorun and when PT you
just the restriction to a if you mark of
CH doing
that a you let your mark of cholve and
getting out of
you
oupou because you are
ked but  you can do all
the liiting when T is going to Z and you
have you can said you can define
directly the L of generat
and
important because doing that you can
to yes here now you can go to the limit
for T small and you get that  with
generator this but it's not the trigger
user inequality because this is this
quantity which is not thegger and you
would like to come back
to are notely
yet so to come back
of
197 so thetingting you take a compa
manifold compa because you don't
want  someone said if you take the la you
will have the
spectum take compa manif there is
no
generoup and the definition since it is
s which can be arassing you can consider
subset you know when you say A1 A2 etc
you just take subset which are
smooth it  doesn't change the definition
of the
lamb
regular
and then you can come back to the result
of Tiger look at the proof not difficult
and you find that for you can find a b
inside a that this RA which is RA RA
this
is
Theure dimension D  - dimension associated
to compute B take you can find B that is
less than thatquare
becausequ so using that you see you have
the L N inside a which you can find bi
so it
need
for equ of
const
can use you know l plus they are all
doing  people concentration you can def
that but
just so this is the ratio of the measure
you really have a set like that now in
the it's no longer as before something
like
that before it was the edge b b meuring
like that and you RA as usual if
n  The Quing
theer n equ yes n equ so now you
can using the
prev prev the fact that lambda0 can be
approximated by quantity to the square
it's easy by using the previous result
of to go and to find AER inequality for
theue which was the question this
morning
ing there is another B in the other
direction for N equ the spectral gap is
bed that and here you have
to is lower B
ofi quantity in fact the LDA n is
equivalent to the en not know why they
saying before so this is a case  where
you this is not like en this is as en
squ when they are going to to zer so the
question before it was if you have for
graph with positive rich curvature you
cannot
do proven the way not
ingasououp we have seen it's really
important the way  we have define the
lambda so everything
goes you have the same
and depend only on the dimension not
di
but what more important that's with
that's all the ID came to consider
such
quantities so now you long you still
keep
your compact manifold but you  add a
drift which is a of a function so you
are given a function on your manif
and
invureure
ah function wasting form form you exend
it
but because it isluence of for
me
weing yes
and
one
and it is operator which is self into L2
of beta  bet
qutity is
here so now you can wonder what is the
behavior of of
the value for beta large so there was a
famous paper by say that this is this
is and
look
and
bet
that here you infum of you
somewhereal
and
where a that all inside  the for you are
below the B and the
con
and
and you take a you take the bottom of
the and you take the which doesn't inter
this one you can see it another
way
possible to not one
by
what you do put you
from
there  you
can
and
coeffent
if
ifuse
that
N and can
find for me
motivation
qu necessary is because not
quantitative so said there is one
particular case where it is quantitative
and du to W now we take the traditional
P you go from L2 to L4
and
if
if  then you can
find a lower B of the spectral gap in
term of the difference between two and
number but is you Cann do better because
if you are given some K which is larger
than two you can findk of
that has
cy
Two Two
anyureernel but anyy  two
point
form you make optimization over everything
and you find
this that the
of because the there
is there is a link between
and
so as was
prev two prev previous in fact you see
before the there was always the same
Indes there was LDA N and but  you can
move a little little one he said in the
talk before 1.1 you can put
1.10.1 the
const
is light
e which is logarm and no longer power
and as this is in fact optimal you
cannot replace that by something going
slow SL which be  in the good
directionon
there won give
you
bute
FA space which should be smaller than L2
so you take a
function function fe which is such that
in to R2 is going to plus Infinity so it
means that the early space associated to
this function is smaller than  the L2 ini
so you are wondering i am going from L2
to this other one so
yes
iftive
version
if is related directly to the
function if there is something like that
then I can give lower B on lambda
n using the
prev
constant this is the same  computation as
before in particular you see there is no
the essential spectrum is not going up
to one because
youue which is
not
back to
theous
if I
can fact plusinity
and
conttive so quite yes trans plusinity
and one if you want something more sub
you can
consider  space ass function then
you
Toal space is going to infinity but not
Infinity
or
generator you take some P and you put it
in the
machine before and you
get
bingue of
the is B by
con seem
B because we know that
NEP
use you know hrtivity in  factable
byation
if
theoupening for if n times youect Be
N
use I use
usually few slides and I remember also
fr had
some
accomplished
put x log put F to the F you can do it
here you canif enery and this this
OFC
the crial par when the
of
ah I you can do the working with two
point you just do
thes
see
you to what
saying
war
ah was using
two
kindergard
I